he just met me but I'm Charming enough
to run a cult surely uh sure all right
great great I'll take it you've already
got a bunch of fans you just all you
just need I mean you already have a
holiday podcast I have a holiday April
18th is a sacred day you know and works
on that I'm an atheist so my one would
be something like I'm God I'm God in
this this world right and the afterlife
will be
ah you just get to hang out with me a
bit more
basically my cult is me
um singing karaoke in the corner and uh
and girls clapping that sounds fun and
loads of in and out yeah yeah but what
what do these people get out of it again
and the thing is the fatter I get the
prettier I am right that's you have to
believe that it shows a sign of wealth
you have to believe that the fatter and
then then they'll come in like oh Jim's
looking very holy at the moment and I
mean like damn straight get me some
chicken